well I saw it as a constituency MP I
used to go around the nursing homes and
residential homes in my constituency and
I could just see them getting bigger and
bigger and more and more people slipping
into this sort of world of darkness and
I remember some sort of specific
occasions where you could see a son in
his 50s talking to a mother in her 70s
and she had no idea who he was and you
could see the Heartbreak on his face and
you saw that so many times and then
was that plus to be honest it was sort
of a slight sense of shame that I think
I was one of many people who thought
well dementia it's what happens when
people get old it's just part of aging
it isn't and when I came to understand
actually this is caused by diseases
diseases of the brain like Alzheimer's
and where cracking cancer we're cracking
heart disease we're cracking stroke why
aren't we cracking these diseases of the
brain that's when it became a sort of
passion for me as prime minister and we
we did some good things of doubling the
research budget making a G8 priority but
we've still got a long way to go this is
I think the Health crisis of our time
dementia we're a country of 60 million
people and there will soon be one
million people with dementia are you
hopeful this is a disease that we can
treat the battle against these diseases
is like a marathon Race you know it's a
26 mile race and if you look at cancer
we're probably in mile you know 18 or 19
lots of cancers we now know how to treat
and prevent but we've still got
somewhere to go I think with Alzheimer's
and the other diseases that cause
dementia we're in like mile nine or ten
we will finish this race we will get it
done but we've got a long way to go when
I first started on this I think we were
rather like AIDS in the 1980s we we knew
this was a massive problem there wasn't
a cure but massive amount of
philanthropy and research and government
action helped to get us there and that's
what we've needed with Alzheimer's and
the diseases that cause dementia now the
Breakthrough is recently are very
encouraging some drugs that really seem
to be reducing the build up of these
proteins in the brain that many
scientists think are connected to
alzheimer's the great about medical
research is when you get one small
breakthrough you then get a huge amount
of enthusiasm and there are over 140
drugs in trial so I'm hopeful but there
still needs to be government action
philanthropy as well as the
pharmaceutical companies coming in as
well and once come on to that is that
hope they're important because I think
right now there's a sort of attitude
amongst people that outsides may affect
not to come forward not to speak to
their GP not maybe even speak to their
families because the feeling is there is
nothing to treat this disease do we need
to get over that attitude of
is it a defeatism yeah we absolutely I
mean like with all diseases there's a
period when there's a sort of stigma
attached almost and we need to get over
that
we need more people to come forward we
need to have uh better tests and better
diagnosis and sometimes the diagnosis is
wrong and I I know how bad that can be
and that's why one of the big things I'm
working on is this early detection of
neurological diseases Edon and what it's
doing is basically bringing together
Tech and AI with science and working out
that of course there are lots of
fingerprints lots of signals that you
might be getting one of these diseases
it could be the way you sleep or the way
you walk or the way you talk or the way
you use your mobile phone so we're using
mobile devices things like fitbits and
headbands and telephones and apps and
collecting all these digital
fingerprints because we think they will
be the way you diagnose much earlier are
people getting these diseases we our aim
is to diagnose Alzheimer's 10 to 15
years earlier than today although there
is a lot of Hope for people with with
Alzheimer's at the moment arguably
they're being failed by social care
system and that's having a knock-on
impact on our Health Service as well do
we need to really focus on fixing the
social care crisis yes I think there are
two parts to this there's there's one
part which is how do you make the NHS
and social Care Systems work better
together there's then a second problem
which is the cost of long-term care that
is what the dill not cap so-called the
cap on care costs which you know my
government commissioned and looked at
but didn't Implement that's that's what
it's there to to deal with I I still
want us to do that but I I still come
back to this issue of it seems to me
that is a classic case for where you
should have some form of insurance to
try and deal with these catastrophic
costs now the insurance industry hasn't
been able to do that and the conclusion
I I would come to is that government
needs to form some sort of partnership
with insurance or perhaps even provide
the insurance itself there are
precedents for this government did that
many many years ago to protect
businesses from the catastrophic costs
of terrorism but on the other hand if
you ask General taxpayer to support the
catastrophic costs faced by people who
are own their own homes you're asking
often less well-off people to pay in
their taxes to protect better off people
from losing their house and that's why I
think there might be an insurance answer
but I try not to get involved in current
political controversies but it seems to
me that's something that we need to look
at Harder putting the ball maybe a
little bit back more back into your
course I mean do you think austerity was
one of the causes of the current social
care crisis we're in I mean looking back
is that something no look when I became
prime minister in 2010 have we faced a
very difficult economic situation we're
forecast to have the biggest budget
deficit anywhere in the world it was
forecast to be over 11
and the decisions that we took weren't
wasn't the sort of voluntary choice that
we sort of opted to do difficult things
in terms of spending we thought it was
the only option to try and make sure
that our economy was stabilized and then
went on and grew which it did and you
know by 2013 2014 we were the fastest
growing economy in the G7 and the
country was doing well and all the way
through that we protected the NHS and
the NHS had real-term spending increases
all the time I was in government but did
we solve the problem of funding social
care no we didn't the deal not cap came
forward as an idea and the reason we
didn't go ahead with it is whenever you
looked at taking that money out of
General taxation you were effectively
asking less well-off people to pay their
taxes to support better off people to
keep their houses and and my wish is as
I say we should look again at Insurance
based options because that might be the
right answer to stop people having to
sell their home to pay for care you were
prime minister when going to make peace
in Annex Ukraine what would your advice
be for those negotiating with Russia at
the moment well I think the first thing
is I completely support the very strong
starts the UK and the U.S government has
taken against Putin I mean if you go
back to 2014 we were the government that
saw it as an invasion and it was because
of Britain that the asset bans and the
freezes and the sanctions were put in
place and I remember fighting for them
very vigorously in the EU Council when a
number of other countries are saying
well it's a bit more complicated are we
sure it's really an invasion it was an
invasion and what has happened
subsequently is even worse so I think
the first thing is for the government to
keep up its staunch support now of
course we'd all like to see and enter
this conflict we want to see Ukraine
Ukraine's borders properly restored and
I don't want to sort of comment in
detail about that because I'm sure there
are all sorts of discussions going on
that that should be going on and the
most important thing is not to get out
in front of an undermine in any way
president zielinski and the Ukrainian
people who've shown such bravery
encourage at this difficult time